I'm going to give an overview on the
beginning of Islam and regardless of
whether you are part of an Islamic
culture you are practicing Muslim or you
believe in the Islamic traditions it's
valuable to learn about the beginnings
of Islam because today nearly one-fourth
of the world's population either is a
practicing Muslim or has grown up in an
Islamic tradition now the beginnings of
Islam really are centered on the life
and the revelations of the Muslim
Prophet Muhammad now the term Islam
means surrender and as we'll see a lot
of the revelations of Muhammad are about
surrendering to God about the oneness of
God about not worshiping idols and to
put Muhammad in perspective on a
timeline I have other significant
biblical figures here and these are
important not just to get a reference
towards Christianity and Judaism but
because according to Islamic tradition
Islam is built on top of the teachings
of Abraham or the teachings of Moses and
the Torah and the teachings of Jesus
Muslims believe that the Quran is the
final Testament so to speak now get some
- get some context Muhammad was born in
sixth century Arabia and sixth century
Arabia was an interesting place in many
other videos we've talked about various
empires around the Mediterranean around
the Mesopotamia and Persia and even on
this map in the time of Muhammad you see
significant empires the Byzantine Empire
the eastern Roman Empire
you have Sassanid Persia but Arabia was
never really consolidated or ruled by a
formal or most of Arabia by a formal
government or a formal Empire the rule
of law in most of Arabia in the world in
which Muhammad was born into was a
tribal world where you protect you're
protected by your tribe and it was
really the laws of vendetta and revenge
that kept certain things in check but
also would lead to a lot of war
a lot of violence and it would in Arabia
there were many folks who are bed wins
who are nomadic people who traveled
through the the desert allowing their
livestock to graze on whatever a
suitable land they found but you also
had settled people in places like Mecca
you had played people who'd settled and
started agriculture around oases
remember most of the Arabian Peninsula
is really desert and Mohammed was born
into a fairly or a very prominent family
in Mecca he was born to the Quraysh
tribe and the Quraysh tribe was
essentially in control of Mecca and
Mecca was a very powerful City to
control because it was a religious
center for the region this is the Kaaba
which exists today and is the center of
Islamic worship and at the time it
housed hundreds of idols which were
important to the various tribes and
people of Arabia at the time and so you
can imagine as they did the pilgrimage
towards Mecca to worship their idols it
also benefitted the economy of Mecca in
a significant way and not only was
Muhammad born into this powerful tribe
he was born to one of the most powerful
clans within that tribe and within one
of the most powerful houses within that
clan but even though he was born into
this very powerful family clan and tribe
his early life was quite difficult
his father died right before he was born
his mother dies at the age of six years
old and then his grandfather who is who
then takes custody of him and by most is
by most accounts he doesn't get a lot of
privileges there's when you're a member
of a tribe but your source essentially
orphaned the tribe is doing essentially
just the base necessities to keep you
alive but then his grandfather dies when
he is 8 years old and he becomes he goes
under the custody of his uncle Abu Talib
now as he grows older he does learn a
skill he essentially becomes a merchant
he goes on trading journeys with his
uncle Abu Talib to places
like Syria and as he does that according
to Islamic tradition he gets a very
favorable reputation he gets these
titles like al-amin the trustworthy one
or al Siddiq the truthful now he
continues doing that until the age of 25
at 25 years old something very
interesting happens a very wealthy
widows arguably one of the wealthiest
people in all of Mecca who runs a
trading a vast trading enterprise
Khadija who was 40 years old she employs
Mohammed and apparently is so impressed
by his honesty by his his ability to be
trustworthy that she proposes to him and
he remembers she's 40 this would be her
third marriage and he is 25 and he
accepts the proposal now this is
significant because as we'll see on in
this video in the next cathedra is the
first one to follow Mohammed or believe
in Muhammad's revelations so he
continues to do to work with his life
arguably work for his wife and then in
610 he's now 40 years old he is praying
in a cave or on the outskirts of Mecca
and while he is praying he is purported
to get his first revelation from God
according to Islamic traditions and that
first revelation and this is the
mountain where it is purported to happen
the mountain of Light Jabal al noor this
is the cave cave hira the first
revelation is proclaim in the name of
thy lord and cherisher who created man
out of a clot of congealed blood
proclaim and thy Lord is most bountiful
who taught by the pen taught man that
which he knew not and so Muhammad
according to Islamic account he's kind
of very concerned by this he does not
view himself as a preacher he does not
view himself as as someone who should be
a prophet and he goes to Khadija and
he's worried and cathedra takes him to
her Christian cousin who reassures
Muhammad who tells Muhammad that
he believes that he is a prophet in the
tradition of Abraham and Moses and so
that to some degree makes Muhammad feel
a little bit better and he doesn't have
some revelations for a while and he
becomes concerned but then he eventually
starts to have many many revelations but
he keeps it to himself at first but
roughly three years later he starts to
publicly preach these revelations so
these revelations which really talk
about the oneness of God there's no god
but God it's very appealing especially
to some of the economically lower strata
but you could also imagine it's very
very threatening to the establishment of
Mecca you have to remember the
establishment of Mecca it revolves
around the the worship of these idols
and now you have this guy a member of
the Quraish tribe the tribe that that
worships who Baal the tribe that is in
charge of mecca that benefits from all
these people worshipping these various
idols he's now saying that idol worship
is a sin he's saying that there's no god
but God that all of these idols are
false idols and so the Quraish tribe
Muhammad's own tribe begins to
significantly persecute the early
Muslims so much so that many of the
early Muslims have to migrate from Mecca
to the kingdom of Aksum which was ruled
by a Christian king who protects them
from the Quraish tribe this now
modern-day Ethiopia or Eritrea and so
things are not going well for these
early Muslims they're really they're
they're really in the on there being
targeted by the Quraysh tribe they're
being killed they're being tortured and
then things get even worse for Muhammad
in 6:19 you have the death of his wife
Khadijah and just to get a sense of how
powerful Khadija was to Muhammad we have
this quote that we get from the hadith
which are accounts of Muhammad's life
and sayings and it tells us God Almighty
never granted me any one better in this
life than her she accepted me when
people rejected me she believed in me
when people doubted me she shared her
wealth with me when people deprived me
and God granted me children only through
her this is once again according to the
the the the sayings or the life of
Muhammad as accounted for by one of the
Hadid and not only did his wife who up
to that time was his only wife died and
was a significant figure but in that
same year his uncle also dies so you can
imagine this year
6:19 often referred to as a year of
Sorrows it's a it's a fairly low point
for Muhammad he's been preaching for
about or he's been getting these
revelations and preaching for around
nine years now and things are not
looking good